The main film is exploring the genetic breeding model.
How to make machine learning
This algorithm is easier to interpret and present
Here are some small robots learning to walk or learn to play Mario or learn to jump high
Genetic algorithm is outdated but still useful
And I personally think that the genetic algorithm will rise in the future.
Once the computer computing power is close to the point of scaring people
However, the most popular technology today is deep learning and recurrent neural networks.
This is why the importance of linear algebra continues to increase
The feasibility of using a short film to explain is getting lower and lower.
But let me use a small movie to explain a little how they work.
Just to make it clear that it would be like this:
There is only one student in an infinite classroom.
The test of the teacher's algorithm is unchanged, but now the "creator algorithm" is the "adjuster algorithm"
Each knob determines the sensitivity of each neural link in the brain of the student algorithm
There are a lot of nerve connections in it, so there are so many knobs
Super super
The teacher gives the student a picture while the adjuster adjusts the knob
Make it stronger or weaker to bring students closer to the correct answer
Much like adjusting the frequency of the radio
Is there a radio now? Does the car have this thing?
I don't know how to forget it.
You should not know the exact frequency of the station you want to listen to.
But can you tell if you are close to the station you want to listen to?
This is similar to this algorithm but with more than 100,000 knobs and a lot of mathematics.
Again, this is just for one problem.
When the teacher takes the next picture
The adjuster must adjust all the knobs so that the student can give answers to two questions.
As the test grows longer
The amount of mathematical operations and the number of fine-tuning are getting bigger and bigger.
But when done, the student algorithm
I can recognize the images I have never seen very well.
Although there are still some problems encountered in the main film
In short, this is an introduction to the simplest neural network you can hear.
If you are interested and you like math and writing programs
Go and find out more.
The machine that can be learned is everything in the future
Perhaps literally - "everything in the future"
In view of how we treat robots, I hope they can be a little better for us.